[Applaudissements]
il va se passer une construction de vie
mes frères vous avez 250 ans frère la
vie elle est morte d'ailleurs j'ai un
service à vous demander
est-ce que je peux avoir parce que je
voudrais justement l'emmener faire un
petit voyage j'ai tout prévu et tout ça
tu veux deux trois jours de congés
deux trois mois merci
merci j'osais pas vous le demander en
fait
[Rires]
toujours avec ta meuf toujours dans le
sud paradis c'est parti
on est sur place on bouge plus
c'est quoi le plus longtemps que vous
êtes resté séparés le plus longtemps un
an après non au bout d'un an moi tu t'es
pas dit c'est mort au bout d'un an non
parce qu'au bout d'un an le l'envie de
se revoir il avait toujours au téléphone
et tout non
un petit message en général
on se dit chacun qu'on s'était manqué au
bout d'un an ouais
et pendant cette année la vécu d'autres
choses
[Musique]
j'imagine mais comment on imagine tous
euh non imagine tout ça
tu demandes pas qui c'est qui a conduit
le bus pendant
la parole de routier non mais c'est vrai
c'est pas un bus coupé sport oui merci
tiens toujours pas toche toi toujours à
ma femme et toi moi
ça fait 15 ans mais célibataire c'est
pas possible si jolie
hein moi aussi je suis beau gosse
je crois que je suis célibataire
de mon enfance
il va falloir que tu t'y mettes un
moment où est-ce que tu vas rejoindre
Daniel
pourquoi vous habitez pas ensemble
franchement
j'arrive pas j'ai pas le truc avec qui
que ce soit quoi
les critères
je vais te dire le premier truc c'est le
charisme
c'est très difficile à trouver tout le
monde n'a pas de charisme qui a du
charisme autour de cette table autour de
cette table à partir de
Benjamin
er